[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Washington DC is a
divided city but today saw a moment of
rare political unity lawmakers in both
parties came together in grave agreement
that it was unfortunate
unacceptable indeed threatening that
President Trump would refer to poor and
dangerous countries as in effect poor
and dangerous now some of the outrage
was tactical obviously a way to score
political advantage but a great deal of
it was entirely real it was authentic
rage so why are the people in charge
hysterical about this is it because
Trump said something racially
insensitive let's see just yesterday
Nancy Pelosi dismissed the daca
negotiation because there were too many
white people involved and most people
here didn't even notice
so left wing attacks in the basis of
race are now common very common so could
it be they found it shocking the
president would criticize an entire
nation
maybe but then the left has no problem
bashing huge parts of this country
you could put half of Trump supporters
into what I call the basket of
deplorable ''s right
the race is sexist homophobic xenophobic
as llama phobic five white guys I call
them open hamburger stand next door what
so they don't have a problem dismissing
entire populations so what is the real
reason for the panic you're watching
right now in cable television
maybe it's because Trump's remarks are
forcing precisely the kind of
conversation our leaders don't want to
have he didn't do it on purpose it was
accidental but he still raised questions
they'd rather not answer like who
exactly are we importing into our
country and how are they doing once they
get here answer of course well they're
all fala dick torian's and war heroes
and in fact way more impressive and way
more American than you will ever be so
shut up that's what we're told that's
what we're required to believe what if
it's not true last year the u.s.
accepted 23,000 people from Haiti and
172,000 from Mexico immigration from El
Salvador has been so brisk in recent
years then 1 in 3 Salvadorans now lives
in the United States as America become a
better country as a result maybe maybe
not maybe we ought to talk it through
and decide before we continue with our
current immigration policy leaders who
actually cared about their people would
do exactly that and yet our leaders just
yell at us until we stop asking
questions Senator Lindsey Graham of
South Carolina released a statement
today that neatly summarizes how most of
official Washington thinks about this
subject in a statement Graham dismisses
the idea that America should even think
about what kind of people it lets in
quote I've always believed that America
is an idea Graham wrote not defined by
its people but by its ideals diversity
has always been our strength not our
weakness America is defined by its
ideals okay so what are those ideals it
might be useful to know considering how
important they are
well diversity is our strength is the
only one or leaders seem to agree on the
less we have in common
somehow the stronger we are is that true
we'd better hope it's true because we're
betting everything on it but there's a
deeper problem with what senator Graham
said quote America is not defined by its
people really what do its people think
about that are they pleased to learn
their leaders consider them merely a
commodity a set of interchangeable parts
America's actual people with their
actual families and towns and traditions
and history and customs may be surprised
to learn that they're irrelevant to the
success or failure of what they imagined
was their country according to Lindsey
Graham you could take our entire
population and swap it out for 320
million I don't know Chinese or Indians
or Africans or Canadians or people from
New Zealand and the place would be no
different so long as the idea was still
there does anyone actually believe that
how about we test that idea starting
with the US Senate would South Carolina
get the same representation from someone
randomly selected out of the phonebook
as Lindsey Graham would say the Senate
isn't defined by its people it's really
just an idea and as soon as you start
defining things by ideas rather than
individuals people become irrelevant
jason nichols is a professor of
african-american studies at the
university of maryland didn't joins the
same professor thanks coming up thank
you so this isn't a debate from my
perspective over whether or not the
president is vulgar yeah is it's a much
bigger debate about people and do they
matter are people interchangeable or all
populations the same so if I took your
neighborhood where you live and took out
everyone who lived there and replaced
them with other people from somewhere
else well the neighborhood be the same
so first thing since you said it's about
people I do want to mention a couple of
people I'd like to mention US Army
sergeant Mario Nelson who gave his life
for this country Mario Nelson was born
in Haiti yeah he left a three-year-old
daughter who's now a teenager if she's
watching this show I want to give my
condolences but he gave his life for
this country my friend Paul who but his
his very good friend while he was in
Afghanistan died in a rocket attack she
was born in Kenya but if you're if
you're expecting me to be surprised I'm
not at all I spent part of the day with
a terrific guy from Haiti I mean there
are a lot of great immigrants here
including from Haiti
salvadore and a lot of countries you
wouldn't want to live in and they're
great people I'm not contesting that at
all okay I'm merely saying the idea that
all populations are the same or the
people of America don't have a right to
determine who comes here or if you take
a ton of people and replace them with
another group of people that it's
everything's exactly the same if they
the same idea that's just not true well
then if we if we believe that we like
the way America is right now then why
are we trying to get rid of large
numbers of people who are here look I
could we can play that I know what
impressive immigrants aim and I would
agree with you in every case because
there are a lot of impressive image okay
but there also a lot of impressive
native-born Americans it not impressive
need our help two of us already who need
our help there are a lot of them sure
but the idea that it's somehow
outrageous are bigoted to say that there
are differences between countries or
cultures that's insane that's why what
is what is outrageous and bigoted among
many things that our president has said
what is outrageous and bigoted is to
select certain places and call them crap
holes and again I'm gonna edit myself
here but to call them crap holes now
again Haiti and continental Africa have
very little in common other than the
color of the skin of the residents who
live there the other thing that I would
say is this he talks about we want
people from Nigeria but we don't want
people or we excuse me we want people
from Norway but not from Nigeria now
again Nigeria has a higher GDP than
Norway does it is the wealthiest country
in Africa so he say anyone's a very mean
I mean look it's it's hardly relevant to
the point but it's Norway I don't know
but I do you're wrong on that one point
in Norway I think its richest country in
the world no actually the GDP the way I
saw it was I think it's 300 okay look I
mean the point we get a ton more people
from Nigeria than we do from Norway if
buy from Norway don't have to leave okay
there's no reason to leave North Norway
use the age of 16 if if you were really
interested in helping America you would
want the most impressive people you
could find some would be from Nigeria
some would be from Norway so
would be from Togo some would be from
Japan to move here but you would rate
them on the basis of how impressive they
were you would not say the first people
to get here people have relatives here
you don't run your college that way
Harvard doesn't let in the first 7,000
Salvadorans who apply they say no no
we're taking the best only why don't we
do that I think we do do that as a
matter of fact one of the things that
you said about Nigeria the last time we
were here is that they have a higher
median income and are more educated than
native-born Americans when they get here
Nigerian immigrants so no they're not
going back to their huts as the
president said hey there are people
really hard do really well you if you
are claiming that we are bringing the
most impressive people here then you
don't know much about our system which
gives overwhelming priority to people
who have relatives here being related to
someone is not a qualification it's an
accident so we don't have that that's
not a criterion that Apple uses when it
hires people if you really cared about
America you would say we're only taking
the best well devise a test to figure
out who they are but we're only taking
those people again I think sergeant
Nelson was the best he came here he
sacrificed his life for this but I agree
I'm not I'm not contesting that then so
then what I'm not so you're saying my
argument yes if you came here who work
extremely hard and do and some of them
do very well and we also have people who
come here and don't do well it but the
point is nominated people the same way
the point is not them this country
belongs to American citizens period okay
so that's that's where we start but
second if you ran your college like we
run our country or Harvard ran its
college like we run our country or any
company did it will go out of business
and would suggest that people ran that
company or college didn't really care
about the enterprise they were in charge
of because they weren't trying to find
just the best why don't we do that I
don't understand again I think that our
immigration system certainly needs work
it needs some changes however the the
president has made this about race and
ethnicity and that's the problem he
really I don't I don't I kind of miss
that the president said we should have a
merit-based system that's not what the
president said the president said
certain we don't want people from
certain crap holes you know and it was
referring to the African continent
he was roaring our immigrant look I'm
not hearing you I'm sure you're
correcting his I mean you're not here to
correct what he said I'm here to make
the case for acting on behalf of our
country with a merit-based resident of
the United States and you said those
things we could sit here and have a
discussion about that be 100% open to
that Oh what do you really be is the
problem is you are sitting here and
making an argument that the president
hasn't met by an item then it's looking
I think as a general matter we pay way
too much attention to the brain
droppings of the president I'm making
any other people am the real Kovac once
the White House has issued its plans
which have been rejected out of hand by
Democrats which would end chain
migration make this a merit-based system
and a diversity lottery and install you
verify universally so we're not giving
Jocelyn let's talk about someone with
those ideas let's talk about some of the
other things that the administration
right now has taken it as increased the
amount of people that they're trying to
deport and it's talking about leaving
800,000 young people who have lived here
like my friend Nancy Ryusei since the
age of three why I'm trying to keep
we're not allowing for people who are
here illegally if I show up at Harvard
without enrolling in certain classes and
they kicked me off campus are they
immoral for doing that like what if
someone has been here since the age of
three and didn't choose to be here and
they this is all that they know yes that
is any non class the daca recipients
what is it as you know but people who
commit crime sure here illegally
why do they have a right to be here I'm
told it's not about cross as a matter of
fact since the Obama administration the
people who are being detained okay I
just want to treat our country with the
love and respect that you treat your
college with that's it absolutely and I
want a country that sticks to its values
right one of the things that is our tech
ting its own people one of the things
that is on one of the greatest symbols
of freedom in this country of course is
the poem that talks about the huddled
masses he talks about bringing poor even
homeless people and yeah
a lot of we've done a lot of that and
that is something that we stand for is
yeah what we stand for is protecting our
own people because it's their country
doesn't belong to people from other
countries that belongs to us we're
Americans that's the whole point of a
government and I don't think our
interests are being looked out for first
I just don't yeah I would disagree with
that all right I think I agree with you
that I think this administration is not
always looking out for good to see it
absolutely